hey guys it's Jan here from flicks in
the city and I cannot tell you just how
excited I am to be here today with my
new mate
baymax yes we're here to find out all
about Disney's new movie which is
inspired by Marvel Comics it's called
big hero 6 and it's full of humor it's
full of heart and it's full of
high-octane action so join me to find
out more let's fit both baymax hello I
am baymax Tadashi programed me to heal
the sick and injured on it's lovely to
see you here today to talk about big
hero 6 it's one of those movies which is
a beautiful kind of combination of lots
of different things it's a mash-up of
Disney and Marvel we've got east meets
west in there we've got high-tech robots
meets human beings what was it about it
that made it pop for you well it really
came out of my childhood passion of
loving Disney and loving Marvel and and
the thought of mashing those two ideas
up together and and when I found big
hero 6 I really sparked to the the comic
because I just love the characters I
thought they're very fun and I love the
the sort of Japanese aesthetic to it and
but more importantly I think it what we
saw is that there could be a really
emotional story here about this
fourteen-year-old super genius who loses
his older brother and the older brothers
robot becomes sort of a surrogate Big
Brother or a healer and so it had a lot
of great elements to it and and but most
importantly it was the emotion now you
mentioned the characters are on there
fantastic characters in the film which
one do you see yourself as being most
liked and which one would you actually
like to be and why yeah it's I am the
most like Fred because he's such a big
comic book nerd and and that's that's
definitely me
Fred reminds me of when I was a kid back
home and we would get lost playing
superhero in the backyard and that's how
Fred is approaching being a superhero on
this movie so I am I am a lot like Fred
I wish I was more like go-go I think I
was just she's so cool yeah she's so
cool and I would love to be go-go
definitely I let her woman up line as
well now if you could mash
anything else I have you could do any of
the meeting of different worlds what
would you love to actually bring
together the next if you could do
anything do anything yeah hmm maybe
London and let's see London and maybe
like what Shanghai that'd be kind of
cool interesting mashup I don't know
what we call it obviously now we've got
the first animated superhero movie from
Disney now it makes me think I wonder if
there could be other animated movies
like for example Star Wars now if
someone said to you what would you think
about doing an animated Star Wars movie
what would you say done well I probably
have to pick me up off the floor because
I was such a Star Wars fan as a kid but
you know it what's what's interesting
you know you what would give me pause is
they have such an established world
already going in live-action with the
Star Wars films and Marvel had such an
established world already going in the
in the live-action Marvel films and so
with big hero six you know it's very
unique in that very early on Marvel
encouraged us to make this our own they
said don't worry about setting it in the
Marvel Universe create your own universe
so that there was a an amazing amount of
freedom in that so it would be tough to
duplicate that but that's why I really
enjoyed making big hero 6 and of course
everyone loves the film it opened in
America to wide critical acclaim word of
mouth was great box office a fantastic
opening in the UK soon and sure it's
gonna be exactly the same situation
everyone loves it here and so we want to
know what are the chances that we're
gonna see a sequel because at the end of
the movie we feel we want to see more of
these characters well it's very
gratifying it and to hear that um the
currently we have no we've not we
haven't talked about it at all
just because we just finished making the
movie in October when it came out it
came out in November actually in the
States and then we've been promoting it
we know we've been going around the
world and trying to get the word out
there so we I really haven't had a lot
of time to think about it or talk about
and so and after we're done with this
promotional - we're gonna take some very
long vacations and then we'll get back
together and we'll talk about it and and
you know we really do fall in love with
these characters over the course of
making they become very real to us you
know and so the thought of spending more
time with them is not an unappealing
thought I mean if you could have
anything happen in that world in future
what would you love to see happen would
you like to see them go who would you
like to be in there because obviously
we've got the ending we've got two
different cards going on haven't we that
very Matt's gonna be different different
types of baymax
oh you're talking in the portal yeah
that's so funny you bring that up
because my kids have been pitching me
sequel ideas to big hero six and it
revolves around dark baymax coming out
of the portal to fight good baymax so it
seems like the children of the world
want to see a battle between the
baymax's so I suppose we would have to
deliver that that sounds like a great
idea
I'd love to see that definitely take up
your kids kids pitch there if you could
bring any other comic book characters to
life or any other comic book series who
would you love to see on the big screen
animated yeah that's a that's a tough
question really because um you know I
felt I feel like we kind of did it with
big hero six and we you know if anything
I would rather see more adventures at a
big hero six because I felt like you
know we just you just developed this
universe in this world and it's so rich
and there's there's so many places to go
with it so it's hard to say for me and
also because the Marvel guys are doing
such an amazing job in live-action with
their world and their universe and I'm
such a fan of those so you know I it's
hard for me to say I mean going forward
what kind of breakthroughs would you
love to see happen in animation so I
know you had a lot on this movie
Hyperion denison and other things that
really helped you push forward the
visuals and the feel of the story and
the emotions didn't you what would you
like to see happen next going forward
that we could really make a difference
to you know take animation - can't
believe it would be another level after
this well that's a hard one to say - you
know because I felt like you know it's
hard hard right now having just finished
this film to open my mind up and see
what else we could do because I feel I
feel like we can do anything you know
and and we are such it's such a creative
Renaissance at Disney both artistically
but also
technically and anything has a director
anything I can imagine can happen and we
have an amazing group of artists and
technicians that will make it happen
so the desire of mine to put to have a
really rich cinematic you know look to
this thing they put their heads together
and came up with a program that could
deliver it and so it you know a it's
hard to say other than you really the
sky's the limit
and finally Easter eggs in the movie
always a big thing on there there's some
brilliant ones in this film have
spectacular point what your personal
favorite is though and what in the
future in any film would you love that
to be an easter egg for what would it be
hmm
well Fred's room has a lot of Easter
eggs in them and and some some sort of
really a really really obscure Marvel
characters are in Fred's room the you
have to look really close to see and so
I'll I love the fact that we threw in
you know some some really obscure Marvel
characters there and what would I want
to see as uh as an easter egg hmm that's
an interesting question well you know my
favorite animated film is Dumbo or Peter
Pan so somehow you could work tumblr
Peter Pan and then one of these CG
animated films as an easter egg I think
that'd be pretty cool fantastic
don't it's been lovely talking to you
thanks so much free time and
congratulations on big hero six it's a
wonderful movie thank you so much I
really appreciate
you